Um homem de 75 anos que tem o GNA E4, se
o valor de centoide dele, né, esse
marcador aí que usa as quatro
características for cinco, que é
relativamente baixo, o risco dele
desenvolver comprometimento cognitivo
leve durante a vida é de 56%.
Já não é pouca coisa, né?
Agora escuta aí, se esse mesmo cara
tiver um centilo de 100, que indica
acúmulo pesado de amiloide, o risco sobe
para 76%.
É praticamente certeza que ele vai ter o
problema. E para as mulheres é pior
ainda. Uma mulher de 75 anos com o mesmo
gene. Se o centoide for cinco, o risco é
de 69%.
com centóide de 100, 84% de chance de
desenvolver comprometimento cognitivo.
Quatro em cada cinco vão ter problema.